Portia's added a new GTS to its cayman
range the first two seater GTS coupe a
to hit the market and it's already the
flagship the new Cayman GTS struts it's
tough on the circuit my orca and true to
the Cayman name alligators can move very
fast indeed
is it hot dish on my director car
testify no dicen Wolfer explains the
Cayman GTS was made for both the
racetrack and the street GTS stands for
granturismo sport which like so many
things with Porsche has a story behind
it back in 1963 the response a portion i
know for GTS race car that was street
legal and that was the concept behind
the new cayman GTS it's ideally suited
to both the track and the street window
before the and strike a guiding its
abajo so did I talk
the straight-6 buxar engine of the new
top-of-the-line caiman is based on the
cayman s is 4.3 liter powerhouse
optimized fine tuning bumps its output
up to 250 kilowatts and adds 10 Newton
meters of extra torque to make it 380
the cayman GTS with the Porsche dual
clutch unit makes the sprint from 0 to
100 km/h and 4.6 seconds and just breaks
the 280 kilometer per hour mark at
maximum speed
you
the sheets are Lionel points out that on
paper the difference between a Cayman S
and a Cayman GTS isn't that much maybe a
tenth of a second off the acceleration
time and a few more kilometers per hour
of the top speed but in the journey
receipt especially on the track the
little differences tend to add up to one
big 11 Kevin get yes the Porsche active
suspension management since the chassis
10 millimeters lower and heightens
agility the optional Porsche torque
vectoring or PTV gives the GTS better
handling the PTV selectively breaks or
locks the differential on the inside
wheel going into curves to enhance the
car's steering precision and agility
namadi ho chi minh former race car
driver volta world describes the regular
cayman s as a perfect car now Porsche
has added a bit more oomph to it with an
extra 15 horsepower plus a slightly
redesigned interior but for him the
decisive point is the sound inside the
car at the press of a button drivers get
the look and feel of a real race car the
new Cayman GTS is cabin also strikes the
balance between the street and the track
the instruments are logically and neatly
arranged and the surfaces are a joy to
the touch especially on the steering
wheel
but it's the engine position that really
qualifies the Cayman GTS for the
racetrack a butyl Mouton vada oral draws
the comparison with Formula One the
highest racing class where the engine is
mounted midway between the axles to
achieve the ideal weight distribution
the disadvantage though is that it takes
up space in the cabin the engine sits
right behind the two seats so he says
there will always be fans of the 911
with its rear-mounted engine and fans of
the mid-engine the real high-performance
sports cars teen who likes to squat
wonky standard on the new GTS is the
sport chrono package with stiffer
mufflers and a sport exhaust for the
throaty racing sound the sound is as
much a part of a Porsche as its body
styling
some can I get to ask the new Cayman GTS
vinyl Dyson over coins the term everyday
sports car saying that GTS is just as
good for city driving or zipping around
country roads or down the autobahn but
even without much converting it can also
be taken out on the racetrack and there
it does what Porsche GT esas I've always
done best drive fast it's all the tweaks
and nips and tucks that make the
difference does it Porsche is asking
more than 77,000 euros for its
all-purpose sports car in Germany over
10,000 euros more than for the Cayman S
that would pay for lots of concert
tickets but then the Cayman GTS comes
with its own Orchestra and back for an
exhilarating sound and driving
experience